Sweden did play this role of the
contrarian it was a very inconvenient
counter example to all these other
countries in the world that had locked
down and this was the kind of coverage
that he would see the New York Times in
July 2020 Sweden has become the world's
cautionary tale you had uh them saying
that Sweden put stock in the sensibility
of its people and for that grave sin the
coronavirus is blamed for 54 5420 deaths
which is 40 percent more than the U.S
per million people 12 times more than
Norway seven times more than Finland six
times more than Denmark we heard a lot
of these comparisons to Sweden's Nordic
Neighbors in particular Donald Trump was
out there tweeting Sweden is paying
heavily for its decision not to lock
down the United States made the correct
decision we've got clip from Trump that
I'm we're going to play here where he's
making essentially the same point let's
roll that
uh now they talk about Sweden but Sweden
is suffering very Gravely you know that
right Sweden did that the herd they call
it the herd uh Sweden's suffering very
very badly uh it's a way of doing it but
uh the you know everybody has been
watching everybody else and so far
almost every country has done it the way
we've done it we've chosen to do it if
we didn't do it that way we would have
lost hundreds of thousands of more
people okay
and then I want to get your reaction in
a second Johan but first just back to
back with that clip I want to play a
clip of what you were saying in that
same period that was from April 7th
2020. this was from about a week later
what you were saying about the
experience in Sweden and what how people
should think about it let's roll the
clip of Johan from April 2020. my
personal point of view I'm not an APD
meology homologist I can't even
pronounce the word
um it seems like I'm obviously not an
expert when it comes to these issues but
so far I'm broadly sympathetic to the
Swedish model
restricting freedoms might be necessary
during pandemics but only when we have
good reasons to assume that this will
help us when it comes to our long-term
health and when we don't know I think to
what we do know as John Stuart once put
it in every instance the burden of
making out a strong case lies not on
those who resist but on those who
recommend government interference
so that was a very humble and cautious
defense of Sweden's approach what was it
like for for you during that time period
uh you know cautiously defending Sweden
amidst this Firestorm of criticism of
the country's approach
yeah we weren't popular at that time and
both of
friends and foreign media got in touch
and asked me are you all crazy have you
gone crazy over there because it's
there's a pandemic and you seems like
you haven't noticed so I had to explain
not myself but I had to explain the
Swedish model again and again and I
think precisely for this reason exactly
what Donald Trump talked about here that
everybody did it everybody except Sweden
locked down societies entirely and then
in that case
first of all why did they do it and it
seemed like Trump didn't have much more
of a suggestion than everybody did it so
we didn't that's actually exactly what
researchers say when they look into this
the moment when Society is locked down
was not related in any way was
impossible for researchers to find any
kind of correlation with the state of
transmission of the virus geographical
location number or a capacity of the
Health Care system and things like that
the one thing it correlated with was
what did the Neighbors do what did
countries close by you did so it seems
like it was a bandwagon effect rather
than looking into the data the research
and doing a cost benefit analysis people
just did it because obviously it is if
you do a Mis if you make a mistake and
the country suffers it's okay if
everybody did the same mistake then you
could say we had no alternative we just
had to lock down for example but if
you're the odd man out and you make a
decision and your people suffer then
everybody will blame you and so
countries just panicked into this kind
of lockdown policy and and swing was the
one place where that didn't happen
it was I mean in a sense that was a huge
risk right that it requires a certain
um
I think courage on the part of Swedish
pandemic authorities
I think it did especially because
um you know they would be the ones to
blame if things went wrong and
um
but what they were saying all the time
is that it isn't us who've taken this
risk we're the one place that actually
didn't enter into an unprecedented Panic
position of locking down entire
societies economists schools like that
well health authorities had wargamed
pandemics before the World Health
Organization and and others and no one
has suggested that we should lock down
entire societies but then suddenly when
this happened and China started to lock
down and then Italy everybody just got
on board and I think is also so
interesting about this excuse me
Interruption but the thing that I think
is so interesting about this is also
that like China had an especially uh
just astonishingly intense lockdown um
you know neighborhood level enforcers
going door to door and you know these
mandatory quarantines that made it so in
many cases you had families trapped in
their Apartments sort of you know
legitimately unable to even in some
cases go outside for a walk depending on
when the virus was surging in different
neighborhoods and regions
um but the thing that's kind of
interesting is like not all lockdowns
are structured the same and like China's
was considered to
um authoritarian and full-throated and I
guess difficult to enforce for that to
be implemented in other countries but
it's odd because Sweden got I think
especially at the beginning of the
pandemic a different treatment as an
outlier even though China too was an
outlier in its Civ like severity
um that's kind of stunning to me that
the onus is on the
um people emphasizing freedom freedom of
movement uh people's ability to continue
to go to the weddings and funerals of
their loved ones it's fascinating to me
that the authoritarianism didn't require
as much justification but the freedom
did
yeah and let me just jump in there
because because you know uh it was the
the justification that was being used to
criticize Sweden so harshly was always
it wasn't that it was that the death
rate was way out of whack with every
other country that was doing lockdowns
it was specifically
well if you compare it only to the
Nordic it's Nordic neighbors if you
compare only to uh Finland and Norway
and Denmark it looks bad at this this
snapshot in time
um you know if you were comparing it to
the United Kingdom or Italy at that time
it's it's not going to look it's not
going to look as as bad
um and so that that implies that there's
other factors at play perhaps than just
whether you're locking down or not but
uh we have a clip of uh Sweden's State
epidemiologist Anders taniel responding
to exactly that point
um uh that was uh put to him by the uh
BBC interviewer on on a very tough and
and good interview uh back in 2020. so
let's roll uh a segment from that
interview and I'd like for you to
respond to it the brutal truth that you
have had many more deaths in Sweden than
you would have had if like your
Scandinavian neighbors you had imposed
an early and very strict lockdown policy
I think that's very difficult to know I
mean the death toll in Sweden is mainly
in the long-term
facilities for long-term ill elderly
people and we had very much an
unfortunate spread in those facilities
in a way that that some other countries
had but not there are Nordic neighbors
and and why we are displayed in Sweden
and not in our other neighboring
countries that's something we're trying
to investigate now but but with respect
Dr teniel isn't that part of my point
that you probably would not have had
that catastrophic spread of covid-19
through your care home homes
particularly around Stockholm if you had
run a more strict a less open policy for
the general population yeah I mean these
these people meet a lot of people even
if you have a lockdown so you can't
isolate them so in that way a lockdown
would not have stopped to spread into
them and we can see now when we are
starting to look at these places
we see a decline in the incidence in
those places once we start really
focusing and getting them to focus on
basic hygiene procedures and so on
so taniel defended himself by saying
that it was too early to say whether
lockdown saved lives or just delayed
inevitable deaths how does that look in
retrospect
yeah there are many factors here and let
me just mention one important difference
here between Sweden and other Nordic
countries we got the virus earlier at an
earlier stage partly because Stockholm
kids are home on a winter break in early
February and many go to the Italian and
Austrian Alps to ski exactly at the
moment when the we had the peak of
transmission in in Italy so it was
already within our societies especially
in Stockholm and then the Elderly Care
Homes before there was any discussion
anywhere about locking down societies so
this goes to the three we saw more of a
coronavirus surge in Stockholm
than in you know Malmo for example
because of the timing of school breaks
exactly and that's a very important
point you could see that Malmo and
Gothenburg are second and third City in
Sweden had more of the Norwegian and
danish experience because they didn't go
on a winter break down to Italy at that
time because the winter break comes it's
staggered so it comes at different
moments in time and this goes to one
important traditional point from
epidemiology the reason why they rarely
recommend countries to shut down borders
and and traffic and so on is that the
moment you begin to think about doing
things like that it's already too late
because it happens once the virus is
already there and then you only hurt
yourself in other ways hurting access to
everything from health workers medical
supplies and trade and the economy and
so on not to mention the human toe also
I don't know what your family situation
is but my family like my family split
between the United States and the EU and
so to some degree when you begin to
close off borders it puts a lot of
people in very difficult situation
situations where depending on their visa
status and their passport they might not
see their family members or their loved
ones or their partner for many many
months on end which is a huge human toll
that I think frequently are policy
makers there's no way to attach a
monetary value to that but it is a
profound sense of loss this is such an
incredibly important point because
that's exactly the kind of perspective
that would never appear to uh the
technocrats at the decision table sort
of we've got to have to do something
about X but then there are so many
variables that are incredibly important
to human beings that cannot be
Quantified to that extent and that they
cannot have knowledge about not meeting
your loved ones not meeting friends and
family and so it could be almost as
dangerous to health as uh as getting the
virus so and that's a reason why a
policy based on recommendations gives
you that sort of incredibly important
loophole you're able to do things that
are so important to you so when you look
at the the total death toll and the uh
aspects of Health you have to look at
other things as well not just kovid but
also mental illness you're gonna have to
look at domestic abuse you have to look
at suicide or X loss of exercise and and
social adaptation in schools in uh
friendship circles and and so on hey
thanks for watching that clip from our
conversation with Johann Norberg about
Sweden's pandemic policies you can watch
the full conversation right here or
another clip from that conversation
right over here